Game of Thrones season, one to 7,
the ultimate recap. Game of Thrones Season One Robert Baratheon
is King and he and his trophy wife.
Searcy travel up North to see Old Buddy Ned Stark
cluster in mind,
everyone in a very Bluff northern accent once it is
cooling.
Robert Fascinate if he wants to be handed the King
net doesn't want it.
But he can't refuse, Meanwhile,
certainly gets caught shagging your own brother,
Jamie by Ned's youngest son bran.
You get shoved out the window crippling but not killing
him.
Ned sad family join Roberts messed up family and they
all had down South to Kings landing apart from Ned's
bastard son Jon Snow.
He joins the night's watch at the wall and massive
structure used to keep the savages in the North far
away from the slightly less.
Savage people in the regular North Tirion,
the dwarf brother of Jamie and Cersei.
Leaves is accused of trying to murder nerd son and
sensors to a trial at the Erie by Ned sister-in-law.
It was a few sandwiches short of a picnic.
He chooses trial by combat and immersed recalled Brown fights
on his behalf of cash.
He wins and tearing goes free because Lannister always pays
his debts.
Meanwhile, in a much warmer place across the narrow sea
daenerys.
Tar Garian, who is the daughter of the previous King
gets married off the Dothraki Horselord,
Carl Drogo. She gets pregnant eats a heart and is
given 3.
Dragon eggs as a wedding gift or brother is a
Dick about the whole thing.
Pogo pause a load of molten gold onto his head
and kills him later on.
Drugger gets mortale. Woon did danarius try saving with blood
magic,
but instead of resurrecting a hobby,
she hatches. The Dragon Age and gets 3,
scaly pets for troubles back in Kings landing net discovers
that Cersei's been banging her brother,
Jaime for ages and sophisticated to the throne.
Joffrey, along with less sadistic.
Air Tom and and not Roberts children after all.
This puts him in a pickle because his eldest daughter's
answer is betrothed to marry the sadistic jerk.
Joffrey Robert gets killed by a pig whereupon Ned tells
Cersei that he knows a sadistic jerk of a son.
Air Searcy bribes city guards,
they put net on trial sadistic jerk.
Joffrey brackets now. King close brackets or does.
This death net dies because it's the law that Sean
Bean dies in everything in which he appears apart from
sharp.
Game of Thrones Season 2 Sean Bean's eldest son Rob
is upset about dad's death.
So declares war with the Lannisters Roberts,
brother Renly thinks he should be King,
so declares war on the Lannisters.
Roberts other brother. Stannis thinks he should be King,
so declares war on Renly.
The Lannisters Robb Stark religion.
MC Hammer in Christmas statuses.
Ginger bit on the side Mila.
Sandra gives birth to a wisp of evil smoke who
kills readily but none of that,
really matters because when Stannis attacks.
Kings landing later in the series.
Tirion Burnsall is boats with Magic Fire and saves a
city in the warmer place dinner is crosses a desert
and ends up in Karth,
where the city. PA shows and Richard O'Brien impersonators try.
Dragons it doesn't end well and she leaves beyond the
wall.
Jon Snow pretends to betray the nights watch and start
shagging a girl called Egret,
who constantly points out in a sexy northern accent that
you know nothing.
Jealous now is because the wild folk in the North
want to all live in the South because they're terrified
of the icy zombie creatures called White Walkers,
who appear at the end of the season to terrorize
a fat boy called Sam in Kings landing so she
finds a new wife,
a jerk. King Joffrey Marjorie,
who's grammar is Diana Rigg,
Sean Bean's youngest daughter, Arias escape the city with one
of Roberts illegitimate kids.
Held hostage, Meanwhile, Sean Bean,
son, robbers captured Circes Lover Slash Brother Combo,
Jamie in battle, but his own mum freeze.
The Kingslayer in exchange for her daughters and sends imposing
man Lady Brienne to guard him oh mom.
Tell me this isn't true finally form award of Sean
Bean Theon,
Greyjoy, who has a fully working penis at this point
destroys Sean Bean's house and pretends to kill his 2
sons.
One of whom was crippled by Jaime Lannister,
remember that and is now carried around by a simpleton
who could only say the word.
Mini sweet giant. Game of Thrones Season 3,
Robb Stark Windsor loaded battles,
but because he disses wild afraid by not marrying his
daughter.
He, his mother. His hot new wife,
his unborn child and most of his men are killed
at the Red Wedding.
It's pretty shocking. This is doubly heartbreaking because Arya Stark
and her unlikely traveling companion.
The hound who was a dim view on people who
name their swords.
People name their swords comes are literally minutes away from
being reunited with them.
That staying with weddings back in Kings landing.
Tirion is forced to Mary's answer.
It was not keen. Searcy is told to marry Loris
Tyrell,
who is not so secretly gay and Conniving Political Wrangler.
Littlefinger decides to marry Sean Bean,
sister in law who is insane in the hotter place
danarius buys an army of Unix by tricking their master
and then using a dragon to roast him alive.
And these unsullied to kill all the slave owners in
the city.
She joins forces, with a band of mercenaries called the
second sons whose leader fancies her and starts to rule
marine with their longtime friend,
Jorah Mormont, who fancies her and retired nights are barristan
selmy would probably fancies but is old enough to be
your dad elsewhere.
Jaime Lannister loses a hand.
Theon Greyjoy loses a penis,
but gains a master in the form of responds bunkers
bastard.
Ramsay snow and gets a new name Reick for his
troubles.
Ramsey gets to become a proper Bolton and helps dad
take over the North.
Well still Jon Snow climbs the war with some wildlings,
but when he's asked to prove his loyalty to them
by killing a man he runs away and egrets shoots
in with a few arrows,
but definitely doesn't kill him on purpose because she still
loves him.
Game of Thrones Season 4,
the season kicks off with jerk.
King Joffrey getting married to Marjorie,
although he's poisoned at his own wedding and because Sansa
fleas.
Kings landing with littlefinger suspicion falls too.
Unwilling husband Tirion. There's a trial and Tirion chooses his
fate to be decided by combat again is just so
happens that sex pest prints over and Dawn is in
town and looking for revenge for the murder of his
sister.
He agrees to fight Ontarians behalf because his opponent is
Gregor Clegane,
the man who killed his sibling,
the fight. And well for either of them,
but Jamie now return to King's landing freeze.
Terrian anyway on his way out.
Terrian strangles his formal ever Shay because she's been shagging
his father,
who he murders with a crossbow while he sat on
the car Z over in the warm place.
Scenarios is struggling to rule slavers,
Baker said. Dragons keep Barbequing people,
which tends to upset the locals and Jorah.
Her best mate. Turns out to be a spy sense
from Kings landing to keep an eye on her so
she banishes them and lots of Dragons in a cave.
In the north little finger smuggle Sander to the Erie
where he marriage.
Ned's sister in law to become Lord of the Vale
even murders net sister-in-law after trying it on with Sansa
finally Aria and The Hound decides had part ways.
After Brianne shows up and has a massive fight with
clicker in junior and leave him for dead.
Meanwhile, the final stock well.
I say final reckon doesn't really count brand continues his
journey of much tedium to the far North where he
finds a magic tree inclines inside it with his equally
TD's traveling companions mirror and Jojen finally there's a massive
battles the army of wildlings try to take the wall.
We fail in an epic fight that sees Giannoni reunited
before she is killed by a child and he realizes
finally but he genuinely loves her after the battle.
Jon walks out to assassinate the leader of the Wildlings
Mance Rayder.
But before he gets the chance.
Stanis breathy in turns out with an army,
he bought by taking a loan out from the bank.
Game of Thrones Season 5 tiny product of incest.
Tom and is now King and lovely.
Marjorie is due to marry him.
However, there's a group of religious nut bars in Kings
landing and they imprison Searcy for incest.
Loris Tyrell for bombing and Marjorie for lying about lawrason
being too pretty.
Searcy eventually goes free but has to walk back to
the red keep in the nude but when she arrives,
he's greeted by Zombie. Gregor again so that's nice.
Meanwhile, brother Jamie travels to dorm with Braun to rescue
his daughter Marcella,
but despite agreeing her release,
she's killed by the former lover of sex past.
Are you keeping up in the hot place having smuggled
out of Kings landing?
Tirion spymaster various hook up with danarius to join her
cause.
She struggling with the rebellion of slave Masters,
which claims the life of sub Ariston.
So eventually she accepts their help so Jura wants to
be danarius'
S friend again? So he becomes a gladiator.
Russell Crowe fights in a tournament to win her trust
and then files in assassination attempt on our life.
When shit gets really serious at the tournament.
One of the nearest is Dragons flies in to rescue
her and she then ride him to relative safety.
Away in the middle of a rampaging Dothraki Horde in
the north little finger gives sensor to Ramsey Bolton,
who takes her as a bride,
then takes her against her will on the wedding night.
Theons helps us to escape and the 2 jump off
the wall of Winterfell together in other stark news.
Aria heads to Bravo, us to join the faceless men
who are a bunch of assassins.
She trains well but breaks the rules by killing all
enemy.
Marian Trenton is blinded for her troubles.
Stanish tries to March South to reclaim his Kingdom but
loses most of his army in a Blizzard and despite
burning his daughter alive for good luck is eventually defeated
a murdered by Brianne. Woon did in the Woods in
the far North.
Jon Snow calls a truce with the Wildlings and agrees
to let them live on the pot side of the
wall,
but most of them are attacked and killed a village
called hard home by the white walkers.
The nights watch aren't too keen on John's love for
the wild folk and they stab him to death at
the end of the season or do they Game of
Thrones Season 6 sensor entheon escape winterfell with a little
help from bloody woman?
Sansa heads to Castle Black,
where she emotionally reunites with Bastard Brother John before helping
him to raise an army to fight bastard.
Husband Ramsey in the fittingly titled Battle of the bastards
wait isn't Jon Snow dead well.
He was, but melissandre resurrects him because John is way
too pretty to die anyway.
During the Battle of the bastards.
Ramsay kills his prisoner Rick on stark.
Tormund bites a man's ear off and John eventually wins
with a little unexpected help from the Knights of the
Vale Ramsey has his face eaten off and start rule.
Winterfell again in Bravos. Aria gets her sight back fails
to murder an actor and finally kills off her longtime
tormentor the wife.
She returns to Westeros serves Walder Frey's sons in a
pie and murders him delicious in other good news for
Aria The Hound is back and is Whit as a
sharp as his axe shithead dying in Allah.
Over in the East, the nearest gets captured by the
Dothraki murders.
All the cars and their own clothes and takes the
army of horse lords for herself.
She gets back to marine just in time to defeat
the slavers and raise a fleet big enough to sell
to West dross?
How does she get so many ships Yaron Theon Greyjoy
after being chased off by mad uncle your own have
made an alliance with her.
In King's landing, Cersei tries to outsmart the high sparrow
fails,
and so just blows him up and a bunch of
other major characters with a shit load of wildfire Tom
and get sad about the death of his wife,
Marjorie, and throws himself out of the red keep tower
that this rather upsets.
The Queen of Thorns, who allies with Dawn against the
Lannisters over the death of her granddaughter.
Meanwhile, Jamie spends a few episodes,
liberating River run from the black fish with Brown keeping
him company with some solid one liners better and things
that any officer the Lannister Army.
That's like saying I have a bigger cock than anyone
in the Unsullied Army.
Sam and Gilly have the most awkward dinner party ever
with Daddy Tarly.
Before Sam steals. The family sword and heads off to
the local library.
Finally, North of the wall bran learns to see into
the past,
present, and future by messing about with an old tree.
It learns that John snow is actually the son of
Ned Stark sister and the Mad King,
son and he finally discovered why Holder is called Holder.
Yes, hold all means hold the door,
which is what mayor shouts are the gentle giant sacrifices
himself to allow her and brand to escape an attack
from the night.
King in a scene I could barely watch through the
tears.
Game of Thrones Season 7,
Daenerys arrives in Westeros finally am breaks into her old
family home at Dragon Stone and over at the Twins.
I have finally gets her revenge on House Frey for
their antics at the Red Wedding and poisons them?
Well, what she poisons all of them and people ask
you what happened here.
Tell them the North remembers.
Tell them winter came for House Frey Danny then sends
her allies.
The Dornish in the greyjoys to attack Kings landing,
but their fleet sunk by mad uncle,
you're on the sexy pirate who captures Yaron Illaria sand
and one of her daughters kills the other 2 Theons
runs away.
Danny sends grey worm to take Casterly Rock,
but the Lannisters are busy sucking highgarden murdering the pension
who lives there and stealing all her valuables by this
point,
the mother of Dragons is really fucked off so she
rides a dragon,
Drogon to burn up all the Lannisters on the Gold
Road.
Jamie and Bronn managed to get the gold back to
Kings landing barely escaping with their lives and an heiress
roast.
The hell out of Randall Tarly and his son Dick
on your cars.
In King's landing your own presents Ilaria and her daughter's
prisoners in exchange for a marriage promise from Cersei.
Jaime does not approve does she like it gentle.
Graph. Finger in the bum Searcy poisons alarius daughter and
makes her watch and then pays off her debt to
the iron bank like a regular student with a Funko
pop addiction. She then borrows more cash to pay for
her mercenary.
Army now when she's pregnant again probably which is nice.
Jamie is the Daddy, the things they do for love.
Jon Snow goes to visit Danny on Dragon Stone,
but refuses to bend the need to her.
Danny let's her mind for dragonglass to kill the white
walkers,
and the pair slowly get cozy wasn't the word.
I was thinking of Danny is chuffed with a military
victory.
But Terrian and John convince it to offer a truce
with Cersei so they can fight the Mass.
Undead coming down from the North trouble is certainly won't
believe them without proof.
So jaunt Orman said. You're a freshly cured from his
grayscale by Sam Tarly The Hound Beric Dondarrion Thoros of
Mir MC Hammer.
Mary Berry Snoop Torgan Gendry.
He's back by the way all head up North to
try and kidnap a zombie.
The Grabber White bag, it up,
but everything goes a bit tits up and most of
them end up marooned in the middle of a frozen
Lake while Gendry goes running back for help.
He makes it to the wall in record time.
But it is under Raven Devil sends a Raven to
Daenerys.
She flies up to rescue them the night.
King kills one of her Dragons and promptly resurrects it
to fight for his army.
Uncle benjen shows up randomly and eyes all in the
space of about 5 minutes.
At the end of the season,
the night. King uses the undead visarion.
The dragon to smash a gap in the wall and
marches army straight through.
Well, this is happening up North loads of people reunite
in Kings landing wrong makes few cock jokes.
Come on, you can suck his magic.
Cock later and all the main players meet in the
dragonpit to discuss a truce.
Searcy doesn't agree. Tirion talks around.
She does agree then reveals she doesn't agree and was
lying anyway that the monsters kill each.
Mother battle in the North.
We take back the man's that belong to us and
then what?
And then we will Jamie doesn't like her lying so
he leaves to fight the army of the dead without
her.
In Winterfell Bran arrives home and starts being all Moody
at IMO arera rides home 2 after a brief chat
with Ed Sheeran hot pie and the mirror and she
reunites with sensor brand just doesn't seem bothered.
You came home little finger tries to drive a wedge
between the Stark Sisters.
But the past secretly plot against Littlefinger and trick him
into showing up at a trial at the Great Hall.
The trials for him. He's guilty of being a scheming
bastard and our ear executes him,
finally after clearing up masses of shit in Assessor,
Al and curing seizure of his grayscale.
Sam leaves with Guillian Little Sam but not before discovering
a rather interesting fact about Jon Snow.
His parents Rhaegar Tar Garian Ileana Stark were.
Which makes Jon Snow a legit tar garian heir to
the iron throne and nephew to daenerys oh?
Well, at least he didn't start having sex with his
anti.
Oh dear and now you're all caught up on Game
of Thrones and ready for season 8.
He's never been a bastard.
Is the heir to the iron throne?